hey Ben so I'm definitely a left-leaning
student but I listen to your podcast
every day thank you for coming and thank
you for listening I appreciate it thank
you so my question is about racing
culture so while I agree with you that
when you look at white America it's
silly to say that the majority of white
Americans are actively trying to prevent
you from getting to where you want to be
I'm East Indian and I have definitely
experienced some racism but I never felt
as though it keeps Indians from
succeeding so I do think there's a
cultural component that supersedes the
color of your skin but I also think that
it's naive to say that it just so
happens that the same minority groups
that have been historically oppressed
happen to have cultures that are less
conducive to success I believe that
environment can create culture can you
acknowledge the historical reasonings
that led that these so-called
unsuccessful cultures and not put blame
on these minority groups I know that in
your heart I don't think you're a racist
person but in my in my opinion to blame
people for their failure for their
cultural failures without taking the
game to consider an historical the
history in general conceals a lack of
empathy and sort of hints at racism
okay so I'll fight back on the last
point that that you know there's
anything to do with empathy or racism
here but I fully agree with you like
100% I think the bad cultures are
generally the result of bad things that
have happened in the past or bad modes
of thought that have prevailed over time
so for example there's a great book by
Thomas solo called Black rednecks and
white liberals and that book essentially
suggests that a lot of the paths the
pathologies that exist about single
motherhood for example in the black
community or high rates of violence are
actually outgrowth of a slave and post
slave culture that was imposed by a
white society that didn't bother with
policing that didn't in that didn't care
about inculcating morals or virtues in
in slaves obviously they actually
actively fought against it because they
didn't want that to happen and so there
was an active fight from a symbol
against assimilation by white people
that created an underground culture
that's really bad and that exists in
parts of white America too it exists in
Appalachia so yes I think bad cultures
have nothing to do with race I don't
think that just because this is why I'm
saying I don't know why borders on
racism to say the cultures are bad like
some cultures
bad some cultures are good and that has
nothing to do with race charles Murray
wrote an entire book called coming apart
about pathologies and white communities
that that are really destructive so bad
cultures do arise very often from
historical circumstances including
historical discrimination what I say is
that today there's nothing preventing an
individual from superseding the culture
in which you grew up and making good
decisions then the free country
somebody's gonna have to break this
chain somebody's gonna have to break
this cycle and so am I gonna I don't
care if you want to if you want to say
that that the pathology that exists in
the black community black intercity
community of highest rates of single
mother and violence for example or lack
of institutional wealth that that is a
result of historic racism I'm fine with
you saying that I don't have any problem
with that I'm not talking about
historical racism when I talk about
white privilege I'm talking about right
now the idea that there's a
superstructure of rules and laws that
are preventing you from succeeding or a
culture that is trying to keep you down
I don't think that's the case so the
question becomes if you are here let's
say let's say that on average the
culture in white America or with regard
to single motherhood to take an example
is is here right because there's less
single motherhood in the white community
than black community and in the black
community it's it's here because it's
70% single motherhood rate in the white
community it's 40% okay so the question
is before thanks to racism and thanks to
discrimination there was a cap on the
black community that was here and they
couldn't get past it okay now that the
ceilings been removed so what do you as
an individual black person do to change
your life and I don't think it's helpful
and in fact I think is actually quite
hurtful to spend an enormous amount of
time talking about the legacy of
discrimination and racism instead of
talking about what can you do right now
to fix your problem now this is a
general issue that I have in all of my
relationships my when my wife comes to
me and she says there's a problem in my
life before we even have the
conversation I say to her is this a
listening conversation or is this a you
want me to fix it conversation
and I think that when it comes to
politics there should be far fewer
listening conversations like I want you
to tell me about all the crap that's
happening it's I don't care I mean I
care but it doesn't but now the question
is what you gonna do right that's a much
more important conversation because we
only have five minutes together is that
five minutes gonna be spent on all the
terrible things that happen which I
fully agree with that I would have
fought if I were there but I wasn't
right we're gonna spend five minutes
talking about all the terrible things
that happen to Blacks and Jews and gays
and women and Hispanics in the United
States are we gonna talk about right now
what you can do to succeed because I
don't think that the rules are holding
you back so I've never ever at any point
suggested that there's not been historic
discrimination against black people or
even that current day poverty is at
least in part an outgrowth of that
historic discrimination when I have
suggested is that if you are using that
historic discrimination is a reason why
you are not as an individual human being
becoming more income mobile and not
making the decisions no one is making
the call for you right now as an
individual to get that girl pregnant and
that's that's the argument that I'm
making sure yeah so I guess like would
you like so would you have to admit
though that between different races and
different cultures there are there are
different levels of success and there's
definitely you would expect that
somebody who grows up with with with
unless with being able less to succeed
you you it's you would expect that that
would happen in certain insert
communities in certain right that's my
tournament pathologies of culture yeah
for sure
I mean if you grow up in a worse
situation than somebody else you grew up
in a better situation of course you're
gonna grow up having obstacles that that
other person has to overcome but that
doesn't mean that that other person
number one victimized you right there's
no one in America today for example
who's enslaved a black person that I
know of or if they have they be in jail
I'm sure that nobody in this room right
none of the young white people in this
room we're alive during the times of Jim
Crow so the question is do we take away
from the white people in this room to
rectify historic and justices or do we
recognize that history is filled with
historic and justices and now we're
going to have to find a way to overcome
those obstacles together without
redistributing income for example now I
have called for movements for example
for for companies to go into inner
cities and make a deal with students in
inner cities and say to them listen you
get good grades and will pay for your
college and then you come after when you
work for us for three years to pay off
that debt I think there are things that
we can do in the private sector this is
why I think religious communities are so
important
I'm not against charity I'm not against
us as individuals going out and helping
people what I am against is the idea
that the government can fix this problem
because the government cannot fix
historic inequity
although government can do is set the
rules at an equal level equal law equal
you know equal judgment under law equal
justice under law is the only way that
we're ever going to approach anything
that looks like a fair Society there's
no such thing as a fair society where
the government plays God and gives some
to others and takes from others would
you say that you basically we should
take other people who are not you know
in a press state they should they should
wait and wait for other people to pull
themselves up do you think that's how we
should solve or do you think there is
I'm reading in every culture in American
history every individual American
history who has succeeded has had a
combination of people who help them out
not in the government people who help
them out and their own capacity to
bootstrap it and when my
great-grandparents got here they were
dirt poor and didn't speak English
great-great grandparents got here
they're dirt poor and didn't speak
English this is true for virtually
everybody in the room right at some
point somebody came over here and they
were dirt poor and didn't speak English
and that doesn't mean that on a
generational level people are gonna go
from from zero to a hundred but it does
mean that we're gonna need to move in
the right direction as opposed to
sitting around and talking about
historic injustice all day because that
doesn't get anything done thanks so much
[Applause]